各位同学大家好
很高兴能有机会与大家在银与开源社区的线上目客相见
我是来自清华大学计算社会科学与国家治理实验室的王立达
今天我将围绕公共数据开发利用及授权运营这个题目
从政策视角围绕着公共数据开发利用的政策体系与意义
授权运营的机制与关键问题以及人工智能时代
公共数据开发利用的思考与建议这三个方面与大家进行分享
首先我们一起来探讨一下公共数据开发利用的政策体系与意义
近年来党中央国务院高度重视数字与资源开发利用
出台了一系列的政策法规进行相应的引导和部署
这里边包括了网络安全法、数据安全法、个人信息保护法等一系列
策中于安全的政策法规也包括了像数据二十条
关于加快数字政府建设的指导意见数据要属成三年行动计划
等更策中于安全的政策文件
从时间维度上来讲我们也可以大概从这张表里面看到
安全相关的文件出台的相对更早一些
近几年相关的政策会更策中于发感一些
特别是在这个过程中
随着二三年底国家数据局的正式接盘成立
像我们明确释放了要大力开发数据资源
充分释放数据要随价值这样一个信号
举行到公共数据领域
在最近不到一年的时间内更是密集出台了一系列专项政策
大家可能也关注到不久之前在五月底的时候
政务数据共产条例正式发布
这个条例不同于前几年的
比如说网络安全法 数据安全法
它不再是一个强调安全的这样一个法律法规
它更多强调的是对数据的如何做好流通和应用
在公共数据方面
去年9月份中共主要办公厅国务院办公厅也联合印发了
关于加快公共数据资源开发利用的意见
对咱们国家公共数据资源开发利用工作的开展进行了顶层设计
与之相配套在25年的1月份出台了公共数据资源登记管理的展行办法
授权运营的实施规范
以及授权营价格形成机制的通知这样三个文件
这四个文件加起来也就形成了我们国家公共数据领域
一加三的这样一个政策体系
在这一系列的法律法规和政策文件中
我们明确了哪些内容
首先是概念
以往不管是在学术界还是实践界
我们对于什么是公共数据还存在着一定的分歧
那随着上述这样的政策文件的出台
我想我们已经可以把我们的思想认识统一起来
在两半意见中明确表达了各级党政机关
起实业单位依法履职或提供公共服务过程中
产生的这些数据它属于公共数据的范畴
从这个概念中我们可以很清晰地看到
我们传统上讲的政务数据
由各级党政机关提供的这些数据
它肯定是公共数据
但是政务数据之外
如果是一些起实业单位它们产生的数据
那如果是基于一些依法获得的特定的授权
那这样一些履职所产生的公共服务数据
我们也要把它放在公共数据的范畴之内
如果没有这些授权
那它就不属于公共数据
我想这个首先是对公共数据概念
层面的这样一个界定
当然在这个20条中
其实当时也提到了有公共数据企业数据
个人数据这样三大类别
但是实际上我们要理解这三类
其实是有相互交叠的
比如说在公共数据范畴之内
必然包括了大量来自于这个起实业单位
以及个人的相关的一些数据资源
那第二个方面
我想在文件中明确提出的
是公共数据开发利用的三种方式
这个在两半亿人中明确提出了
比如说公共数据的开发利用
我们包括这个政务数据的共享
包括公共数据的开放
以及公共数据的授权运营
这样三种形式
在这三种方式当中
共享它其实是我们这个政府内部
或者说公共部门内部
对这个数据资源进行流通
并进行进一步利用的一种方式
主要是这个对内的
而这个开放和授权运营
这两种的途径都非常明确
它更多强调的是
我们要把公共数据资源
面向社会进行供给
要进行公共数据的社会化开发利用
这是文件中明确的三种形式
那后来出台的相应的配套文件
包括政府数据共享条例
其实我们也可以通过这样一张图
能够非常明确的看出
他们之间的对应关系
比如说两半意见中
它是对三种开发利用的方式
进行系统化的介绍和说明
那后续出台的
公共数据资源登记管理的
暂行办法
它更多的面向的是
比如说要做授权运营的数据
那是一定要登记
那不进行授权运营的数据资源
那是进行一种鼓励登记的
这样一种方式
然后公共数据资源授权运营的实施规范
以及价格形成机制的通知
那非常明确
都是聚焦于授权运营这个方面
那政务数据共享条例
自然我们是明确的指向了
是我们内部共享的
这样一个开发利用的途径
所以从中也可以看到
可能共享和开放
作为前期我们讨论比较多
各地各部门都有大量实践的
这样一种开发利用的方式
可能大家相对都比较熟悉
那授权运营
它作为一种在政策文件中
明确提出的
这样一种公共数据开发利用的形式
也是我们现在困扰比较多的
一种新的方式
那如何理解授权运营
以及为什么要做授权运营的
其实我们可以回顾一下
我们之前公共数据开放
这样一种大家比较常见的
公共数据社会化供给的这种模式
它存在什么问题
比如说其实很多人往往一说到
公共数据的开放
都是提说国外在公共数据层面
都是默认开放
但是我觉得这种表述
它可能是不够准确的
比如说在开放数据现场中
它第一条确实就强调了默认开放
但是在这条中还有后半句
它这种默认开放被表述为是
政府应该开放除涉及国家安全
商业机密以及个人隐私之外的
所有数据
这才是对公共数据开放的
一种完整的表述
但是在这个表述下
我们也可以想一下
到底有多少公共数据
是不涉及国家安全
商业机密以及个人隐私的
我们会发现非常少
因为我们的公共数据资源
普遍来自于个人企业
以及社会运行和经济发展
这里边运行了大量的
国家安全商业机密和
个人隐私的数据
从这个角度讲
确实符合默认条件
默认开放条件的数据
并不多
在这样一个前提下
政府如果想想社会
释放公共数据价值
那它必然就要投入大量的人力和资金
来对原始的公共数据
进行相应的清洗加工
然后把这种清洗脱敏之后的数据
才能这种用开放的形式
向社会进行提供
所以这个也是
为什么很多地方
可能开放在前期
做起来比较困难的一个原因
当然同时
其实我们也能看到
在现阶段
就是在咱们各级政府部门的
职责贩酬之内
其实往往并没有把数据开放
作为采集数据
产生数据的这些政府部门
它的职责
并没有化入它的职责贩酬之内
一方面这个职责体系里没有写
没有进行明确的表达
另一方面
如果把数据开放
开放之后
如果出现一些安全问题
它又要承担先任的责任
那从这个角度讲
那也确实都可以理解
可能政府部门往往也会缺乏开放的动力
那所以呢
授权运营
正是在这样一个
公共数据社会化共济
所面临的这种困境的情况下
我们创新型提出的这样一种新的方式
那通过这个公共数据授权运营
我们希望实现的是什么呢
是引入对这个公共数据开发利用有兴趣的
这样一些社会力量
让它参与到这个公共数据开发利用活动当中
愿意去进行一些前期的投入
愿意进行这个人力资金的这样的一些投入
从而替代政府的前期投入
通过这种参与
可以减少政府策的这种人力和资金的压力
同时通过这样一些社会力量的参与的加工和治理
也自然能够扩大我们面向社会供给的这样的一个公共数据的范围
同时在这个过程中
也想引入这种市场化的机制
从而实现公共数据开发利用的
这样的一种共创共享的模式
调动包括公共部门在内
以及各类市场主体
调动大家共同的积极性
从而实现一种公共数据价值的
可持续的这样的一个释放
上面是我们对公共数据开发利用政策体系
极益的一个简单介绍
第二部分我想
我们就聚焦于公共数据授权运营
这样一个比较具体的话题
来共同探讨一下
那公共数据授权运营应该如何来做
有哪些关键的问题是需要我们进行关注的
是如何理解公共数据授权运营
从那个公共数据授权运营现有的政策体系中
我将它体链成为三类主体两个阶段
这里边第一类主体是我们公共部门
这里边既包括了我们的政务部门
也包括了刚才提到了一些产生公共数据的公共企业单位
他们其实是公共数据的供给方
各类公共数据资源都是从这里边产生
然后由这边进行供给的
那第二类主体是运营机构
也就是愿意来参与进公共数据开发利用的过程中
承担相应的一些运营职责的这样一个机构
第三类就是市场测的经营主体
是需要利用公共数据相关的一些产品和服务
来进行各类的经营生产
这里边既包括了公共数据的产品服务的再开发再利用
也包括了一些其他经营活动中对公共数据的使用
这样是三类主体
那在三类主体之间有两个阶段
第一个阶段是从公共部门到运营机构
这个其实更多的阶段强调的是公共数据的授权
是公共部门把公共数据授权给运营机构进行开发利用
当然在这个过程中运营机构一定是要承担着对公共数据资源
它的一些安全保护在合规可控的范围内进行开发这样的一些职责
然后从运营机构获取公共数据资源开始
它其实往下再进行的程序其实就是公共数据的一些运营活动
在运营活动中更多强调的可能是一些市场化的力量
更多的要结合市场测的需求来进行相应的数据产品服务的开发
把这个市场的力量引入其中充分释放这个公共数据资源的价值
那如果我们把这个一个公共数据授权运营的过程进行一个更详细的展开
其实我们可以通过这张图看到这里面一个相对比较完整的流程
在这个整个公共数据授权运营的过程中
我们的地方政府和行业主管部门也就是部委
更多的承担的是一种组织领导统筹管理的相应的一些职责
那从他们往下走呢
那个我们各类各级的政务部门公共企事业单位
他们其实是公共数据的这种产生方
或者也可以说是数据资源的这种持有方
享有数据的持有权
然后同时呢数据管理机构
比如说地方可能就是我们很多数据局 证数据等等
这样一些机构在这个过程中呢
要承担起来对公共数据的这种管理的指责
在很多地方实现中呢
其实也是由这个数据局来建设一个统一的公共数据的这样一个平台
通过这个平台实现对这个公共数据资源的统一的汇聚管理
当然这种汇聚呢可能是逻辑的 也可能是物理的
它要根据实际需要来进行开展
那这个平台呢
首先我们是要支撑政府内部对公共数据的共享和使用
那在这个基础上我们也要考虑到
那我们肯定是要把这个公共数据资源从这个平台往外走
也就是面向社会进行相应的施放
也就是我们现在说的授权运营
那在这个授权运营过程中呢
我们可以看到这个政策文件中还提到了实施机构这样一个感觉
那怎么理解实施机构呢
它更多的是站在这个政府策
帮数据管理机构来开展一些先人的这种监管
一些实施组织运营这样一些工作
那运营机构呢在这个过程中获取到了这种数据
加工使用数据产品经营的先人的一些权利
然后呢可以在公共数据的运营平台上来进行
公共数据的这种加工和处理
然后形成先人的初级的数据产品和服务
面向这个市场侧的各类经营主体进行提供
然后在在这个过程中呢也会有一些
比如说数据服务机构啊
数据交易场所啊参与其中
当然呢在这个过程中我们要做好全流程的安全监管
数据监管行业监管市场监管啊等等一系列的活动啊
那下边呢我们可以结合一个具体的案例啊
来看一下如何来理解啊
比如说这个我们人设部对公共数据授权运营
其实从18年就开始做了啊
这个呢当时呢其实还没有这个特别明确的
说是这个公共数据授权运营这么一个概念啊
但是他做这个事情
其实我们现在讲的这个数据运营活动是一致的啊
当时呢是以一个PVP项目的形式开展的啊
这个相应的这个数据呢是从这个人设部啊
这个相应的一些这个社保的一些数据啊
然后通过这个金宝信这样一个多方共同组建的
这样一个公司作为运营机构啊
然后对数据进行开发利用啊
然后在面向市场侧各类经营主体提供服务啊
在整个这个过程中呢
其实他有一些很有意思的点啊
比如说呢一个是这个运营机构的呃身份确认呢
他是通过这个公开招标的形式啊确定下来的
然后呢在整个过程中
他要对这种项目进行相应的计效评价啊
依托于计效评价结果来开展收益分配
然后在这个过程中呢
他也将这个呃收益的回报设置了上线啊
设的是12%啊这样一个上线啊
那那当然我们现在最近的这个呃
授权运营价格形成机制的通知呢
其实提了一个更低的这样一个限定啊
然后但是呢他这个思路是一致的
是要限制中间这个运营机构
他的收益的呃这样一个呃一个一个范围啊
避免了他从中谋取暴力啊
更多呢是希望通过这样一个过程
把整个这个公众数据开发利用的盘子给做大啊
呃同样呢
比如说我们还可以看到前几年
这个北京金融数据专区这样一个案例啊
北京的金融数据专区呢
他其实当时最主要面向的呢
是这个解决我们如何给这个中小微企业啊
进行贷款的问题啊
大家都知道呢
可能这些企业往往也没有这个相应的一些
这种固定资产是吧
没有相应的一些这个呃可以做抵押的
这样一些呃一些财产啊
那就这就对这些这些中小微企业
他在经营过程中获取这种心态啊
造成了很大的困难啊
那呃如何能够在这个没有抵押物的情况下
证明这些企业
他是这个具有比较好的偿还能力呢
那这个北京金融数据专区呢
就结合着这个公共数据啊
从中发掘价值进行了相应的探索啊
比如说呢
他通过北京大数据平台啊
能够获取到一些这种中小微企业的工商税无
社保医保公积金司法环保啊
等等大量的这种数据啊
这是这这边所这个这个公共部门这一侧
所掌握的数据情况啊
然后呢
基于这些数据呢
他其实呃这个很多这个
银行啊金融机构啊
他可以结合自己的算法
来判断这个企业的相应的一些情况啊
比如说呢
一个这个中小企业他已经经营了十几年了
然后每个月呢都能正常纳税
社保也非常稳定啊
那在这样一个情况下
其实银行是如果能够获得相应的证明啊
基于政府数据的证明
他是愿意给这些企业进行贷款的啊
这样以形成一种这种多方都能够获益的机制
所以这个呢
也就是北京金融专区前期的这样一些探索
在这个这个这个这个普会信贷方面
发挥了巨大的价值
当然了金融领域的探索呢
其实现在不止北京这个一个地方啊
很多地方呢
都是在这个这个这个金融领域的这种数据
这个公共数据价值挖掘
作为一个这种前期探索的方向啊
然后来开展了一系列的工作啊
同时呢
跟这些类似啊
还有像我们这个最高法
关于这个司法大数据的
授权运营的一些案例和做法啊
跟前面的这个两个情况都比较类似
在这呢
就不再进行具体开了好
那当然在这个过程中呢
其实我们也要关注啊
这个公共数据授权运营
它其实呢
也是一个需要这个规范管理的这样一个过程啊
在这个授权运营实施规范里边呢
列出了一些这种关键的环节啊
在这呢
我也简单梳理了一下
比如说要包括啊
我们要编织实施方案啊
也就是确定授权运营的规则啊
这个方案呢
还要通过这个三重一大的决策审议啊
然后呢
完成相应的方案备案啊
构建那个实施机构啊
要检查立志啊
然后呢
进行这个运营机构的筛选
签订相应的协议并备案啊
建设授权运营的平台
然后开展公共数据资源的登记啊
在授权运营过程中呢
还要进行相应的情况的公开
然后对数据呢
进行初级的加工啊
对形成的产品和服务做好公开和披露啊
然后再到后面
这个呃
公共数据的这种再加工再利用啊
以及形成最终的数据产品与服务的攻击
可能这是大概的讲一个过程啊
在这呢
其实呃不再坠述啊
很多细节的东西
大家感兴趣的话
可以从这个呃授权运实时规范这个文件中啊看到啊
呃
那那我想呢
呃下面呢
我也不具体就文件的条文啊
跟大家进行这样的附数啊
我是想聚焦于这个公共数据秀授权运营过程中
呃大家最近关注度非常高
讨论非常多的呃几个话题啊
几个问题
跟大家进行一些这种思考的分享啊
比如说
第一个问题是这个
呃
这个在这个实时规范中明确提出了运营机构啊
不得直接或间接参与授权范围内意交付的公共数据产品和服务的再开发
对这个问题怎么理解啊
好多好多这个地方和部门啊
相应的同时交流的时候都觉得啊
这句话写的比较傲口啊
呃
其实呢
这句话他背后的意思
呃
我觉得还是很直接很简单的啊
核心思想就是要避免垄断和不争当竞争啊
我们可以想一下啊
因为这个运营机构
他在整个这个过程中
他是可以呃一一头呢触碰到这个相对原始的这种公共数据
另外一头呢
他又能够掌握到这种市场测对公共数据的一些实际的需求啊
那在这个过程中呃
如果说这个运营机构呃
他这个这个我们不对他进行限制是吧
那会是个什么结果啊
就拿刚才那个这个这个金融专区这个情况打得不合不太合适的例子啊
比如说北京的金融专区
他是有北京的一个国有企业这个金控集团啊
然后设立了像设立的专业专门的子公司来进行运营的啊
目前整个运营情况比较好啊
但是我们做一个不那么恰当的假设啊
如果这个运营机构不是金控这种机构来做啊
如果它是我们一家银行来做啊
不管是工行农行建行是哪家银行啊
如果是一家银行
那银行也具备相应的技术能力啊
是吧
他也能够对公共数据已经开发啊
也能够这个很好的打造一些这种金融领域需要的数据模型和产品啊
他能力上是没问题的
但是呢
如果是一家这个具体的银行来做这个事情的话啊
那我们其实站在这个这个这个人性的角落啊
我们其实可以想象到他一定会什么呢
一定会把最好的这种数据和产品服务提供给自己家啊
也就是提供给后边的金融主体的时候
一定会向自家进行倾斜啊
甚至呢
有可能还会对其他家的一些经营进行一定的这种限制
那在这个过程中
自然呢
他会出现一些这种这种问题啊
所以呢
这句话的核心意思啊
就是对运营机构在中间充当的角色进行一定的限制啊
你要么你来做运营机构啊
你要有一定的这种呃
公共性公益性啊
把这个公共数据的这种初级开发给做好啊
那在这个过程中
你不要再去想着
我就要在这个后边的市场测去挣大钱啊
那要么你就别做运营机构
你去做市场测啊
市场测的经营主体
那这时候你的收益是不受限制的啊
当然呢
其实我们从这张图里边也可以看到啊
运营机构
他也是可以直接面向这个这个这个产业测啊
直接提供一些产品服务
这个也是允许的啊
但是呢
在这个过程中
他是要实行政府指导定价管理的
就是刚才提到的那个价格形成机制的那个
通知里面
其实是明确提出了是10年期国债加这个这个
可以服从6个点啊
是这样一个收益的范围
也就是说呢
如果作为运营机构的情况下
那他的盈利范围大概是在7.2%
8亿内啊
是在这样一个范围
是避免这运营机构呢
在这个工作过程中啊
能够获取超级的利润
是要通过这个政府指导定价进行相应的限制啊
这是第一个问题
那第二个问题呢
其实呢
这个这个有些部门啊
也会存在一些疑惑实施机构实施啊
那其实很多对地方来讲啊
往往这个问题好理解
因为我们很多地方政府呢
都有自己的这个
比如说大数据中心啊
信息中心啊
这样的一些机构
那这些机构呢
他以往其实就是做了公共数据
规及治理相应的一些工作
那在那在做授权运营的时候
他自然而然啊
其实就成为了实施机构
是站在政府这策啊
进行相应的授权管理监管等等活动啊
但是呢
确实啊
我们现在也可以看到
对一些这种行业部门啊
比如说一些部位
他的这个实施机构的选择上
可能面临着一些
一些困惑吧啊
因为呢
确实可能这个一个是呢
很多部位
他可能没有这样一个
集中统一的
这样的一个
这种大数据中心
这样一个角色
以前是没有的啊
另外呢
在他的业务条线中呢
往往的
有有不同里边
又有一些细分的领域
和和这个条线的划分啊
那这个也确实对他这个
实施机构
这个的确立造成了一定障碍啊
但是呢
我想在这个过程中呢
其实我们是可以各部门各地方
结合私人情况
进行灵活处理的啊
首先呢
我们实施机构并不一定是一家啊
一个地方呢
我也可以结合自己情况啊
设置这个不止一家的
这样的一些实施机构啊
分别开展
可能是不同
这个领域
不同场景
不同方向的
一些公共数据
授权运营的活动啊
这个是可以的啊
另外呢
其实这个
实施机构呢
也可以考虑到啊
他和这个运营机构
以及和后边
这个相应的一些这种工作的
这种边界切分啊
其实呢
从这个原理上来讲
实施机构也确实不是必须的啊
如果这个相应的一些
公共数据的
这个智力啊管理啊监管啊
相应的一些工作
我们政府自己可以解决的话
那我们也可以
不设立这种实施机构
也可以采取这种模式
那第三个问题呢
是关于这个授权运营
能否获得收益啊
关于这个答案呢
其实从政策中
我们可以看到是非常明确的
是可以获得收益的
是可以获得这种合理的收益啊
当然呢
在这个过程中呢
其实我们也考虑到要有
这个要有要有这种合适的
这种核算机制
收益分配机制等等啊
当然这里边的收益呢
我想其实我们指的
也不一定就是经济收益啊
这个收益呢
可以有多种形式啊
可以有这种社会社会收益
是吧
政治收益政治机率认可啊
等等多种不同的形式啊
那从这个这个右边这张图啊
我们可以大概看一下
我们也对授权运过程中
可能存在了收益类型啊
进行了现在的划分啊
当然现阶段来讲呢
可能在这个数据使用费方面呢
还是处于探索阶段啊
并没有获得特别明确啊
但是在这个比如说政治认可与激励啊
社会认可与生育方面啊
这个是大家都可以这个
呃
这个这个通过工作啊
通过这种一些激励手段啊
能够有一定获得感啊
然后然后还有一块
我觉得可能是
我们可以关注的方面方向的
其实就是在这个授权运过程中啊
我们政府不测呢
其实可以获得一定的数据技术
或者服务反補啊
就有的时候
如果这个直接回来钱
不是那么容易回来的时候
是吧
我们其实可以通过一些其他的形式
比如说我可以把这个公共数据
免费给到这个运营机构啊
免费给运营机构去使用啊
但是这个过程中呢
你运营机构是不是呃
可以可以帮我建一些这种政务的系统
是吧
当然这个政务系统本身
可他有可能就是为了
把这些政务数据
能够更好的提供过来的
一种支撑和保障啊
同时呢
那我把这个公共数据给运营机构了
那运营机构是不是也可以
把他所掌握的一些社会数据啊
供给给政府进行相当的使用啊
这也是一种技术反驳
数据反驳啊
这种不同的形式
那第四个问题呢
其实是关于如何选择
授权运营模式的问题啊
在意见中呢
其实提出了整体授权
分领域授权
異常领授权啊
等不同的模式啊
在前期时间探索中
其实各地各部门在这个模式的选择上
都有各自的选择啊
也形成了比较多的典型案例
在这里不再展开啊
在这块呢
我想提的一点呢
就是这些授权的模式并不排他啊
他一个地方
他我可以记住这个
整体化的授权给一家是吧
但是呢
除了这个
这个整体型的给一家
能做这个整体授权之外
可能在具体的过程中是吧
我也可以根据场景啊
再做一些这种一场景的
这种小切口的特殊的授权
也是没问题的啊
他可以是多种授权形式共存的
这样一种方式啊
只要有利于我们把授权运营做好
是吧
只要有利于公共数据价值的施放啊
其实各种各种模式和路径都是可以的啊
第五个问题呢
其实这个也是啊
是关于这个授权营提出之后啊
一些地方和部门存在的困惑啊
它和以往的一些
比如说我们公共服务啊
比如说我们一些社会上
一些市场化的这种数据服务
如何来界定的问题啊
我想这个里边呢
首先呢
如果说我们是传统的公共服务啊
当然也包括基于数据的这些公共服务
他的特点是什么呢
他主要是依赖于财政的投入啊
财政的投入
那那这个在这种前提下
首先呢
可能要更多我们强调的什么呢
强调面向的是公众的普遍性需求啊
是全民要进行平等的享用啊
也是由公共部门主导啊
是这样一个过程
那授权运营呢
刚前面咱们也提到啊
他的核心理念是什么呢
是引入市场化的机制
引入一些市场力量啊
然后来共同来对公共数据进行开发
是吧
把公共数据的价值给释放出来
所以这个呢
可能是公共数据授权运营的特点啊
那再到市场测
其实也同样存在着大量的数据服务
那这种服务的模式
他往往就是比较典型的是企业主导
是中间是市场经营驱动啊
所以呢
我想这是这几这几种不同形式之间的
前面的一些区别
那第六个问题呢
是关于这个授权运营
与数据交易所关系啊
这个呢
其实也是现在很多地方啊
大家存在困惑比较多的一个地方啊
其实呢
我们可以看一下在这个两半意见中
关于这个场内交易的描述啊
其实只有一句话
是鼓励有条件的地区
探索公共数据产品和服务
场内交易模式
我们可以看到啊
这一句话里面有好几个
这个这个修饰的词啊鼓励啊
有条件探索啊
其实所以我们也可以从文件中啊
至少现在文件中
并没有把这两者进行明确的挂钩啊
这是首先是文件的一个表达
同时呢
我们也可以可以再想一下啊
那数据交易所它的价值是什么啊
它更多的实现的
其实是共需双方的一个对接
是吧
能够我知道这个我需要数据
这儿有没有从哪找是吧
那我们也可以想想啊
前面也提到
在公共数据这个几个文件中
明确提出了什么呢
提出了我们这个这个
运营收权运营的过程中是吧
我们所使用的这个公共数据资源
我们所产生的公共数据产品和服务
我们都要做好什么呢
做好公开和披露啊
这个是在文件中的一个明确要求啊
那当然这个公开的公开和披露的
渠道和途径啊
是是可以是多样的啊
比如说我们可以看啊
这个里边放了一个截图
就是成都市公共数据收权运营平台啊
它发布了大量的
这个公共数据的产品和服务啊
那这个其实就是一种公开和披露啊
那这个公开和披露如果做好的话
它自然也可以实现
是吧
我们这个供需对接的啊
这样一个作用啊
当然呢
也有的地方会选择
把这个披露和交易所的这个
公共数据产品和服务上架
结合起来来做啊
这个当然也是没问题的啊
我们其实这里边的核心的
这个这个目的啊
还是能够让这个
把这个公共数据产品和服务啊
让大家知道有什么是吧
能够这个更好地去获取啊
至于它是通过交易所来做
还是通过政府网站来做
还是通过公共数据收权运营平台来做啊
这是都可以的
并没有进行相应的
这种特别明确的要进行绑定啊
那第七个问题呢
其实是关于登记的啊
公共数据资源登记与其他登记啊
有什么区别啊
其实呢
这个里边我想呢
在这个公共数据资源登记的
这个办法里边是吧
其实也做了一些一些表述是吧
首先呢
我们这个公共数据的登记机构啊
它其实是这个由数据主管部门
来进行设立或者指定的是吧
一般要求是这种事业单位啊
然后呢
要对这个纳入数成运营范围内的
公共数据进行登记啊
但是同时呢
其实我们也从文件中也可以看到是吧
目前的公共数据资源登记
它并不是一种
这个这个这个
比如说类似于行政许可的这样的
有一定强制性的行为并不是啊
它更多的强调的
在我的理解里啊
更多的强调的是什么呢
是一种记录与存证啊
就是你做做授权运营的过程中
你要能够讲清楚是吧
我到底有什么公共数据资源
然后我把什么样的公共数据资源给了谁
产生了什么样的公共数据
产品和服务啊
那这些资源和产品服务
我们是要进行登记的啊
通过登记呢
把这些明确下来存下来啊
不能狐狸糊涂的给
然后也不能狐狸糊涂的进行产出是吧
所以呢
这是现阶段
可能公共数据资源登记
他的核心的目标啊
跟这个这个其他的一些登记
比如说也有之前也有探索
这种知识产权的登记啊等等啊
其实并没有特别直接的关联啊
目前来讲呢
可能也并没有起到
这个我们有有一些
有一些这个这个
包括这个机构啊企业啊
往往希望是吧
能够进行产权界定是吧
这公共数据资源产权的界定
可能现在看的
也并没有做到这样一个程度啊
那第八个问题呢
其实关于这个地方和部委
谁来授权的问题啊
因为呢
确实公共数据呢
他往往啊
有有有不一定是这个可能
可能一个数据级啊
可能会有多个部门
或者多个层不同的层级
都会有所掌握啊
比如说啊
我们按刚才那个讲到这个金宝信啊
人设部的例子中
他其实这种社保相应的数据
那可能地方
比如说北京有北京的这个社保数据是吧
那从国家层面呢
他其实有全国各个地方的社保数据好
那这些数据啊
这个从部委和地方层面
谁可以进行授权呢
其实在这个实施规范里啊
是做的界定是这个各级人民政府
和国家行业主管部门
可依法
可将依法持有的这个公共数据资源
进行授权运行啊
所以这是一个前提啊
如果这个持有公共数据
是一个依法持有的
那自然就可以进行授权啊
当然在这个过程中呢
其实也我们也考虑到了这个
政务数据共享的这种
这样一种获得公共数据的方式啊
在这个规范中也做了限定啊
如果你的这个政务数据
是通过共享方式获得的啊
那你如果想做授权运行
你还是要争得这个提供单位的同意啊
不能自己来做啊
也是你共享获取的啊
当然呢
其实在这个两半的意见中啊
关于这个问题
其实当时呢
我们也提了很有意思的一个观点啊
就是在这个过程中呢
其实我们是要进一步来加强数据
服务能力的
这句话怎么理解呢啊
就是传统
可能我们往往一想到
要对公共数据进行开发利用
首先想到的是什么呢
是我要拿到原始的数据
我要把数据都拿到自己手里啊
这样我才能进行开发利用
是吧
但是呢
随着现在技术的进步
特别是随着这一轮
生成是人工智能的
这样的技术的
这种广泛应用
我们也在逐步反思啊
之前的一种模式啊
它是不是必须的
是不是一定要拿到原始数据啊
所以我想呢
这块呢
也不一定是这样
所以在文件中也提出了
那推动这个数据利用方式是吧
从这种打范围的汇聚啊
向这种汇聚和应用服务能力
并重的方向来转变
是吧
我不一定非要拿原始数据
你只要能够满足我的需求
你通过服务的形式啊
能够满足我的需求就可以啊
这是以上呢
公共数据授权运营
相关的一些机制
与观念问题啊
那最后呢
我想咱们也结合这个
人工智能时代啊
一些新的设定
新的趋势
我们来谈一谈
对公共数据开发利用的
现在的一些思考
呃
最近两年呢
随着这个生成是人工智能啊
这种广泛的应用啊
其实在政务领域啊
我们也需要了
也出现了一些这种新的
这种政务大模型啊
比如说这个
政务服务是吧
我们有一些这种智能问答的机器人
是吧
能够提供一些政策咨询啊
然后办事的导演啊等等啊
在机关办公领域呢
比如说可以这个
由这个大模型帮我们写公文啊
做一些写作
在社会智力的领域呢
可以进行相应的一些智能的
监测讯解啊
辅助执法啊
面向几个决策领域
这个辅助决策方面的
也可以是基于这种大数据
帮我们做一些决策分析
然后做相应的应急处置啊等等
那这些
这个这个这些场景的实现啊
这些政务大模型的建设
它自然离不开我们后边这种
公共数据的相应的一些支撑啊
那那在这样的一个需求背景下
其实呢
我想我们公共数据的一些
这种应用的一些模式
也在发生着相应的一些改变
比如说啊
我们传统的公共数据
治理和利用的思路是什么呢
我想呢
我们可以非常简单的把它概括为
据通用啊
这样三个环节是吧
我们对这个
公共数据进行相应的采集汇聚是吧
然后呢
进行相应的这种
这种这种相应的加工处理是吧
然后保证它的质量
然后在这个基础上呢
我们通过刚才提到的
类似于共享啊
开放啊等等啊
不同的手段
然后来实现这种公共数据的流通
是吧
所以然后到最后呢
再基于这些能够实现对公共数据的
开发利用是吧
在市场测
让它释放它的价值
这是我们传统的
这个公共数据治理的
这样的一个
一个一个路径
好
那我们再结合
刚才提到的
一些这种
政务领域的人工智能大模型
那我们来看看
他是怎么利用公共数据的
是吧
那那比如说这个
对大模型的这个训练是吧
那为了让模型
能够满足我们政务领域的
一些特殊的需求是吧
他得懂
那这个时候需要什么呢
需要我们把政务的一些数据
能够形成相当的训练数据
训练数据
它有可能比如说支撑我们
专用的政务大模型的这种训练
也有可能我们把这些数据提供给
市场上的各种通用大模型
来提升这些通用大模型的政务能力
这也是可理
但不管这个数据怎么用
那这个数据
即它从哪来
它必然要来自于我们不同的政府部门
不同的层级的政府是吧
要把这些政务数据能够通过
比如说共享开放等等不同的手段
把它让他们这个流通汇聚起来
能够产生进一步的价值
提升我们模型的能力
当然呢
除了模型训练之外
其实现在在政务领域
我们还有一种非常
这个普遍的应用模式是什么呢
就是把大模型外挂
我们的政务知识库
对吧
那政务知识库的构建
其实跟刚才这些训练数据
的构建是一样的
那我们这个政务知识库
我们面向什么方向
那我们自然就需要这些方向的数据
尽可能多的从不同的部门
不同的层级
能够获取到相应的这种数据
知识来构建
形成我们这样的政务知识库
那这种形式呢
它自然我们可以看到
跟上面的剧通用的
这种传统的这个这个公共数据的
治理和供给的模式
它已经产生了显著的区别
好
但是呢
我想呢
不管不管怎么来说
不管是我们传统模式中
还是现在面向这个人物智能的
这种公共数据治理呢
那我们如何来做
如何来实现做好
其实呢
首先我们要做的第一步
还是对这种数据
资源的基础治理与准备
这个呢
不管是以前还是现在
哪种模式都是绕不开的啊
在这个里边呢
其实我们也一直在提
提倡一种呢
是要把这个数据
和政府的职责进行绑定啊
那个通俗点说啊
我们有时候把它说成
可能是从三定到四定
我们以前政府
我们确定职责啊
对职责的描述可能是
那个比较
比较这个这个十几句话吧
条理性的这种文字性的列在这
那那那然后从这往下走呢
他可能有对应的这种业务事项啊
要进行新的旅迟啊
那再往下呢
我们可能建议相应的系统
那这时候数据是什么
数据是系统的负产品好
那在数据时代
在人工智能时代
可能我们理解那这种方式
我们要有一定的调整和优化啊
那跟政府职责对应的是什么呢
就刚才提到了
我们是不是要定数
那在定职责的同时
那政府有什么数据
应该采集什么数据
应该产生什么数据
其实是要和职责进行紧密绑定的啊
那通过这样一个逻辑链条啊
我们能够把它给建立起来
那自然我们有什么数据
应该有什么数据啊
这些数据从哪里来到哪里去
我们就能明确下来啊
那这个通过这样一种手段
做好这种数对政务数据
公共数据的这种基础治理与准备
我想呢不管哪种模式
这都是第一步啊
那么第二步呢
我们就是要做好这个高质量
政务数据及和知识库的构建啊
这也是人工智能时代
我们实现这个政府治理创新是吧
最这个政务领域
人工智能大模型部署应用啊
这样一个必然的要求
那当然呢
在建完这些这个高质量数据
及和知识库之后
其实我想呢
我们还要再回过头来
也要再强调共享与附用的问题
是吧
这些呢
数据及和知识库
它其实也有很强的
这种共性的附用的价值
是吧
在这个过程中呢
我们一样可以依托
这个全国一体化的政务大数据体系啊
来对我们形成的
这种训练数据
习是吧
相应的一些这种
可以附用具有通用型的知识库啊
做好他的一种
共享和附用的工作啊
同时呢
其实还有一个方面
我想我们要强调的是什么呢
就是对这个政务大模型的
这样的一个一体化的管理服务啊
这个一体化的管理服务呢
就包括了我们刚才提到的数据啊
当然同时呢
其实也有相应的
比如说政务网络上的算力资源
还有我们在
政务网络上部署的一些这种
大模型训练形成的一些大模型啊
在这个过程中呢
我们也要考虑到
如何把他们进行相应的联通和附用啊
比如说我们可以打造这种政务领域
生成是人工智能的
统一的这样的管理服务平台
形成要素资源的一本账
做好相应的资源的监控啊
并进一步推行这种调用和附用啊
那在这个过程中的安全
其实也是不可忽视的一个方面啊
那政务大模型
他的数据的安全问题
其实与以往的数据安全啊
也存在一些区别啊
在这个过程中呢
我们要面向
比如说公开数据
内部数据
设密数据
个人数据啊等等啊
不同的一些数据
我们要做好分类分析的处理啊
然后呢
对政务大模型
相关的一些不同用途的数据
比如说训练数据
微调数据啊
卖卦知识库
那这种不同类型数据
他的安全管理
其实要求也是不同的
这也是我们要有明确的
这种这种这种
这种新的这种管理的制度规则啊
进行相应的区别对待
同时呢
还有一点呢
是要做好这种
相应的一些数据内容的安全啊
因为大模型呢
他会这个有大量的这种
相应的数据的
这种输入和输出啊
也会自动产生大量的内容
所以在这个过程中
我们要落实对这种
一方面训练数据的
这种质量评估和违法的新一线产
那同时呢
也要对这个一些生成的这种数据和内容啊
做好相应的安全防护
同时呢
在这种大模型应用的过程中啊
特别是随着我们这个
现在智能体的这种发展
我们必然会和这个
政务领域的很多的系统平台
进行相应的对接啊
那在这个时候
我们也要做好这个对政务领域
这种大模型
这种输入数据啊
或者说我们接生产数据
相应的一些安全和保护
好
那以上呢
是我今天跟大家分享的内容
不当之处呢
请大家批评指证
谢谢